oh yeah it's that one mercenary that was
in the first season was kind of cool but
she was killed by the end of the episode
and there have been so many other
important characters introduced since
then so let's run that
back for sure bokeh tan sent me to talk
to you
the best part about having a ubiquitous
helmet on the show's protagonist is that
you can freely play around with adr for
these previously on segments
amanda said this line way after this
point in the fight during the last
episode
you know it we know it and most
importantly he knows it
it's called lucasfilm limited so when do
we actually reach the limit
is it soon so you're still going with
grogu then
look sw we're the internet we know
things we basically saved that sonic
movie
give me the ball this is admittedly an
adorable scene but why is he starting
this just
now when they're about to land on tython
it had to be at least a moderately long
trip from corvus right wouldn't mando
start trying this playtime along the way
you can have it just like before i'm
sure it will be completely fine
rehashing the name response ball
training parts of the last episode for
the first four minutes of this episode
since you know there's gotta be at least
an
hour of good episode left right when the
nice lady said you had training i just
the nice lady we're gonna find that
place you belong
and they're gonna take real good care of
you it really bugs me how much mando
takes characters at their word
ahsoka didn't really do to help him last
episode except for letting him take the
pointy best car thingy she could have
told him to go anywhere in the galaxy
and his trusting ass would have hopped
on his ship and been on his way
despite this being his only source of
information i always thought bounty
hunters would be a lot savvier
this is tython what since when is mando
going directly from one place to another
without a detour
side quest distracting him he didn't get
a distress call from han and chewie
while they were capturing a rathtar or
something along the way
understand he does not wait is this what
they renamed the rise of skywalker while
i wasn't paying attention
looks like that's the magic rock i'm
supposed to take you to down there
and i found it within seconds of
entering the planet's atmosphere lucky
me
ahsoka didn't give me coordinates
landmarks or even general directions as
to which hemisphere this is on but my
trusty old digital battleship computer
gave me the exact location for
some reason also sure it could be the
right one but
if this is a jedi-centric planet there
could be a bunch more of these things
right
it's like approaching earth seeing an
applebee's and saying well that's
definitely
the correct applebee's i know i'm
channeling auntie edna here but how does
the jetpack not set mando's cape on fire
if you had a jet pack wouldn't you say
ah
decay probably too dangerous i guess
this is it
i'll just walk you across the areola
here and set you on the nipple and we'll
do our best to figure out how any of
this works
does this look jedi to you that's racist
maybe there's some kind of control
or something oh yes nothing funnier than
the old guy tries to find the on button
for a rock routine i'll assume boba fett
picked up the location tracker signal
that gideon's minions put on the razer
crest a few episodes ago but how this
did he get here so much faster than the
imperial goons they're all traveling in
hyperdrive right
i'll see if i can buy you some time
against the one person you saw exit the
ship wouldn't it be smarter to just
stick here and defend the rock while the
kid's in sight
seriously why would he even briefly
abandon his sole mission that he's had
for nearly the entire series and is
presumably near the end of
if you want my armor you'll have to peel
it off my dead body
if you want my such and such you'll have
to take it from my dead such-and-such
cliche
i'm a simple man making his way through
the galaxy
like my father before me call backs the
best guard belongs to the mandalorians
he was looted from us during the purge
well considering all laws are suspended
during that time i think your case is
pretty weak just be glad you weren't
murdered while out trying to shoplift a
candy bar
point that gun away from the kid or i'll
drop you both where you stand
you can maybe drop him where he stands
but she's technically already on the
ground so really the best you can do is
slump her where she lays tell her to
drop the gun after you put down the jet
pack
same time stand down and she does well
before he even moves to take off the
jetpack
show doesn't know how to same time
correctly you look like you've just seen
a ghost
nonsense i don't see ezra sabine or
chopper anywhere around here
also of all the things to say about a
helmeted fundamentalist mandalorian
describing his expression is really one
of the most feudal endeavors
in my case boba fett
you named your abs of steel boba fett
and i am now in his service
shouldn't you say you're in his boba
debt or are you like his boba pet
does he take you to the boba vet when he
plays his guitar for you does he use all
the boba frets
say we're offering a fair deal under the
circumstances this deal is a trade-off
of boba's armor for their help in
protecting grosgu and it
is a pretty good deal but it was never
agreed to by mando so why did boba and
fennick decide to help him after the
events of the episode boba just takes
that [ __ ] later on despite no
acknowledgement that amanda was cool
with it
the fact that mando turns and runs
instead of grabbing his jetpack that's
right at his feet is dumb on so many
levels i'm exhausted
even thinking about it this is
apparently the only parking lot on this
entire planet i guess they don't charge
for the first hour or something
apparently when you need mando taken out
of the battle for a bit you can just
have him make a third attempt at
something that he's already failed at
but this time it knocks him out for a
bit you know
for reasons seriously this is pretty
much the rest of the episode pew pew pew
pew pew boba hits someone amanda tries
to break into the force beam pew pew pew
pew gideon smirks pew pew pew adorable
child gets cuffed what i'm trying to say
about this tiny battle is imperial skip
despite having a clear view of the field
agent may takes out individual troopers
instead of the one setting up the heavy
artillery we get it stormtroopers suck
at aiming even when they have high
caliber automatic weaponry
they are 100 the keystone cops of the
star wars universe
[Music]
also can you graduate from both the
stormtrooper school of aiming at things
and the rick on stark school of running
away from things cause these guys have a
double major
having time to tap your enemy on the
shoulder when there are several others
all around you with guns
speaking of which bringing in anything
except the gun you're already holding
right in your hands and could fire from
a distance instead of running up to the
guy with the sunflower hammer to a
gunfight
yo why does mando leave his ship wide
open here doesn't he have keyless entry
or some sort of fob that can lock that
[ __ ] down
even if there weren't any intruders here
you'd have to worry about space rodents
getting in the cockpit
guess i won't be needing this anymore i
honestly can't tell if this is ripping
off iron man's weapon or yondu zero from
guardians of the galaxy more but it's
clear that john favreau definitely mixed
up his iconic properties for this scene
we have a day off you do not no one
shook on that
or even verbally recognized the contract
there's no service like fan service like
no service i know everything about it's
unappealing
everything web traffic will
to the ship allow officially stalled
long enough for the episode to hit 30
minutes
our work here is done the kid but i'm
still not going to grab my jet pack
because climbing up and down this thing
is so fun
have the dark trooper has been engaged
of course not we sent two strangely
spaced out battalions of the basic white
ones first
like the script required i actually kind
of dig the dark troopers but why are
they called
troopers at all they're clearly droids i
know dark droids doesn't sound as cool
but you could use another word for dark
like black or
dim yeah that's it dim droids and you
could say cool stuff like
you'll never find a solution for my
persistent dim droids push as hard as
you like my dem droids will never
retreat
they're back hello the empire boba fett
plays the pronoun game so that finnick
has to ask who is back
i guess to be fair he could have been
talking about john wick slim shady or
randy quaid's character from
independence day
also no one in this imperial ship
recognizes nor tries to shoot at this
iconic ship
despite it being in full view of the
entire crew oh come on
there's no way this gear shift ball is
still here let alone easily findable
we're already crying about baby yoda
being abducted man no need to twist the
knife
i need you to locate someone in the
prison registry wait
is this everyone in the prison registry
especially in the entire galaxy
she's really gonna scroll through all
these scruffy-looking nerf herders
before she gets the info to narrow it
down
meg's mayfield i know this all happened
a long long time ago and everything but
why does everyone in this universe speak
fluent conversational english but the
text is in our obesh
with these stripes i mean there are
rules i need to follow
they have the kid situational ethics
little known fact both of these
stormtroopers were actually played by
daniel craig
have you ever seen one of these exposing
your darksaber without explicit consent
give me back my son for some reason you
all want to wear the cinemasins
pitchfork m on your body so we slapped
that [ __ ] on some new merch and threw
it in the store
posters hoodies click on the merch below
the youtube player or click the store
link at cinemasins.com
language i'll see if i can buy you some
time
can you please hurry up i'm trying to
use the
phone you were dead your friend here
is only mostly dead there's a big
difference between
mostly dead and all that you couldn't
handle my midriff
okay i'm gonna protect you okay i'm
going take off
see ya
[Music]
dang it the damage is not too bad as
long as the foundations are still strong
we can rebuild this place it will become
a haven for all peoples and aliens of
the universe
you're not ready to play with such
things you'll shoot your eye out kid
you just took one in the jugular man